we have let our talent Booker Spencer
know that we're ready for Gary Busey
Tom Gary bossy say his name gori gori
gori gori boss he's coming in he's uh
he's got a play here in New York called
a perfect crime bullet which is now
through December 4th at Times Square's
theater centers the it's the theater in
Times Square I think it's right under
the snapple sign let's see there is yes
sir
hello I can see guys have you got you
sure Gary with that last time I saw ya
see you got to get a search assist firm
frontrunner oh my god yes you tell me
last time to get a shirt that's a sperm
farmer no I haven't but I've used my
mouth as one the only thing that comes
out of that is bad spit your eyes all
right correct that's right I let it in
it's a tough time to get in the building
because the elevator system is messed up
come on Adrian Adrian knocking Gary over
would you help him out a little bit
Jesus Adrian no no yeah what his job no
he has an Adrian Jesus crazy I get
seated right sorry he's not he does know
what to do your brother family Arkansas
Adrian now put the Mike by his mouth so
he can meet in here or tell me the
poverty level yeah in order to make ends
meet they had to Jack the dog off into a
bag to feed the cat no I done heard that
dump you were that you're the family
buddy I should be I pretended I was the
cat there's over one dog jacker okay so
you you had it not been for radio Jim
here ended up in yeah okay whose look I
just got saw my wife sighs Stephanie
look at me and that's a joke I should
never have told so we'll dismiss that
right out edit it right well kinda it
was stricken from the record that will
never happen again you don't have to
worry about that well welcome Gary Busey
to Jim Norton and Sam Roberts it's been
a while yeah last time you are up here
you were talking to us all about the
what are the words that have initials
for things like you fart was like Oh
abuse ISM you see isn't you telling us
all about the Busey isms last time you
know I don't do it with proper names but
it will
Trump when I was doing celebra Prentice
and TR um P stands for taking
redirection understanding massive power
that's right and it's accurate to yeah
it works for now to sober sober is a
good word total we all need to know it
so ve R stands for son of a [ __ ]
everything's real hey if you're sober
guy is that right Travis in there always
sits sober means slow on booze enjoy the
road but I was like thank you Travis
sucks that's Travis Travis Garrett we're
gonna get you to see dr. Phil quick yeah
yeah have you seen do you know have you
have you done dr. Phil show before no
you wouldn't do it right oh yeah you
would course I've got lots of things
wrong with me
they're all good I'm a good guy what's
wrong with you that's good what's
something that you think is wrong with
you but works in your favor right just
breathing breathing breathing is
actually right though
no breathing is right yes ever wrong I
ask me that question again what do you
say there's a lot wrong with you that
that works what do you think is
something that's wrong with you that
actually is good everything everything I
do wrong
I be able to I'm able to give it a good
silver lining and create a positive
influence in it and the wrongness
becomes a goodness because the goodness
is better than the wrongness
but it's the wrongness that promotes
inspires and motivates the goodness so
wrongness and goodness are the same
thing they're just different colors do
you get that no but I think he's very
hard to argue us yeah yeah well I
thought how much you win you can argue
with him you understand that okay so
it's so-so wrongness and as long as you
usually talk like that so so so well I'm
trying to I'm trying to gather we said
I'm trying I'm trying to gather I look
at a world of the second or in an echo
whoa whoa whoa yeah please I'm not dying
to say hey hey he does that he just
makes these little womanly noises I
don't like it either oh you guys still
living together
no we separated we were seeing other
people what happened yeah he was having
trouble maintaining an erection for gym
which I'm sure you can you know get big
with this dude now you don't just a
little a little uh what do
wieners AUSA jizz or wood that's it come
on try Frank yeah let's get off that
yeah we know about Weiner
no that's ridiculous not at all that's
ridiculous this family's back there is
just coming what's what's going on
are you guys having fun with this show
cuz you're so good at it we love ya I
mean I'm so proud and happy and honored
to be here with you two clowns with
anyway I want to take the words as well
clown yeah and give you a B or C ISM
down I'll see cell Oh W in yeah it
stands for yeah creates laughter on
Wednesday nights we aren't on at night
but the replay is sometime on Wednesday
night so we are a couple clowns does
your family like the Busey isms it seems
like you know it's fun for us because we
see every couple years maybe but it
could get old very very quickly yeah
they know I'm crazy doesn't get old it
doesn't get old
I would I would gather date night what
do you change no that's that's your new
limited way of thinking now right but
you get the beautician book and you read
it and you read open it to any page you
want to and you'll see a word like
simple right simple what does that mean
I know is that mean it's easy right what
simple it means like easy no no that's
one way to define it yeah a simple way
of looking at that's a simple way of
what's simple mean s impl e stands for
see it manifesting precious loving
energy that's what simple means to
manifest that energy if you learn that
with your significant other now that
it's not this dude right unfortunately
yeah you'll get the third base quick you
think that's all it takes
yeah no that's not all it takes is how
you talk make a woman laugh you look at
it like her number her number one
serving you're her number one fan you
love her like the angels of the church
and everything will go real right with
you and the best way to make it right
with a woman right no matter what it is
just agree with her yeah now that's got
to be tough for you though right because
all out o P not an argue where you'll
agree though you're adored everywhere
you go so how can you look at a woman as
if I'm your number one fan wherever
where you're going Gary Busey
talking about my soulmate for 32
lifetime Stephanie Irene Samson Busey
right and she is what I call my angel
with a whip with a wimp yeah that's
exciting you don't see that thing coming
to pop your ear off in a second yeah so
you'll you'll lose arguments at home I
don't lose them I just change them to
make sure I can win at the end how's
that
it's easy yeah just just use your eyes
and use your smile and use the warmth of
your skin to make sure your palms are
sweaty right right right
so just about being charming right yeah
yeah yeah that makes sense to me yeah
they make sense to meet you are you
mocking my voices oh no my Gary had to
go to the bathroom my name is Mick and
I'm a little guy but I have an education
where did you get your education
everywhere I'm good oh so you're more
like a street educated little person
yeah I see I see yeah how old is Mick
get out here oh okay I gotta go
okay smex Lee thing sure about that guys
that's all right I got it I understand
chips here looking smack how much fun
you guys have during the show we are
having a lot of fits great we're having
a lot we got to make fun happen when it
ain't happening right that's it okay
that's the key element to success right
making fun happen when it's not
happening is that a euphemism or abuse
ISM for the word fun and you in is
finally understanding nothing right
right what now do you make fun though
when other people think like hey man
this isn't the time to have fun is do
you want to try to make something fun
and other people get annoyed in abroad
I'm not gonna know anybody because I'm
laughing with hysterically allottee yeah
side inside not outwardly yeah yeah I
see so they can sense that your
intentions are good
my intentions are always good yeah even
even if people don't like my intentions
good it's because they're not thinking
about themselves righteously huh mm okay
yeah it's never on you then it's never
on me yeah it's always on me what it's
always on me but you said it's on them
for not being righteous so tonight when
we go out dinner dinner's on me
got a nice Scott sir you got it if you
got the checkbook No
and that Buddy Holly money no problem
right hey Norton and Roberts you know
that's a pretty good name for a law firm
that works on bent fenders
I think were a couple of ambulance
chasers yeah Gary's really giving us a
beating this morning he really is he
really is so Gary what you're in a play
I mean what your plate starts tonight
right I'm not on a plane I'm sitting
there radios no I didn't say plane I
said play yeah yeah now I'm in a play
and the beautiful thing about this play
is that it has the Guinness Book of
Records of the longest-running play in
New York and has been running it's been
running in 30 for 30 years and Kathleen
Russell has been in the play 30 years
and I'm brand-new guy in the play but I
started out in my and my younger years
doing plays so I love them I know I'm
and it's just so much fun to do when you
go into a play that has that much
history you worry about [ __ ] it up at
all no no no if you worry whatever
you're worried about it's going to
happen
how's the word worry wor washstands for
working on ridiculous routines yearly I
see and you don't do that no there's no
time for that
no so you don't panic that you're gonna
is it hard to do in front of a live
audience after all these years just
doing films no that's better man cuz I
got you got the live audience out there
feeding off your energy your feeding off
them and it's just like a spiral swirl
of amplification in every direction your
artistic being it can make it
you seem have a good memory though like
you for you to remember the sperm farmer
shirt I didn't remember that so you seem
to have like a pretty good really calm
ability so for you dialogue money must
not be a problem are you aware that you
did have a traumatic brain injury no you
know I didn't get you know what happened
in the sixties what happened you're on a
tricycle
you fell off your tricycle in the 60s
you know what I love each other love
fish trying tricycle into a fire hydrant
no I was oh those the 70s and I fell off
my tricycle onto a ditch
got a little way I got a little blued in
it you know what's funny about you guys
right nobody here's the punchline of
your joke but you guys are laughing like
farm animal we're having a good time
yeah yeah that's the point well you
can't have a good time get out we're
having fun right as long as we're
finally understanding nothing what goes
all the men you know that is yeah fine
it's fun fun that's it it's beautiful to
be alive it's beautiful to be breathing
it's beautiful to be loving it's
beautiful to have things to do to
motivate and inspire others it's
beautiful to have life it's beautiful to
have love it's beautiful to be you
because you are the best friend you're
going to have and that's why we're here
we're here to learn the truth of
ourselves right accept it right love it
and when you know the truth yourself you
can simply relax and know everything
coming to you is their truth and it's
not to be judged or hampered or hit with
a bat now if you always been your own
best friend or there's times like I tend
to be my worst enemy sometimes too so we
you at one point like hey I'm my worst
enemy and now that you're doing better
it's like now on my best friend well
what happens when you've had a traumatic
brain injury like you and me tricycle
accident no I got hit with a baseball he
might be right huh no it's a well that's
what I am in the play what I'm a
baseball bad killer what do you mean I'm
an insane genius oh you kill people with
a baseball bat no that means I'm not
acting everything is natural oh boy I'm
an insane genius and no I don't use a
baseball bat I make mine look like
action ants ah so when you had your
brain injury how long did it take you to
kind of use I saw a documentary on that
where guys like some guys never get
better and I'm like what happened when
you started getting better what was it
that first started to come back for you
like when you started to your brain
started the hill oil I had to spend a
two and a half months and Daniel frame
in the hospital and I had to learn how
to walk and talk and eat and dress
myself and the doctor said Gary tell us
when you're ready to go home and I said
one time I'll ready to go home and they
said why when I put my shoes under the
bed I can smell them they said great
Gary keep working on it I know I'm ready
to go home now
why is that well because the hospital is
at the end of the runways and the Jets
won't land because will kill us that's
why all you hear is Jets well for 5:00
p.m. to 11:00
Daniel Freeman's right under the flight
path of LAX and that's all you heard
were jets and they said Gary keep
working on it but I got a two and a half
months early I got out after two and a
half months and I went home and started
over again
short-term memory how to fight with but
all you people out there that are doing
something that's concerning your
computer which sits on top of your neck
you must wear helmet you must wear a
helmet when you're snow skiing
snowboarding bicycling rollerblading
skateboarding motorcycles and I even
wear a helmet in the shower you just in
case just in case you know you might
slip on a soap and I get what you're
saying about computer on your neck you
know he's talking about Jim know I have
a computer on my neck
it's your brain oh how do you like that
I like it's your brain it's not only
your brain but your five senses in your
mind did you lose any of your senses or
did any of them change no they got they
got more keen more delicate really
sensitive yeah it's like whoa you go to
the other side and come back here you
know that there's so much strong life
around you spiritually and you don't
have to be in a religion but the
spirituality is with you forever so you
find it you're more perceptive now well
here's the deal on organized religion
yeah they are built for people to be
afraid of hell spirituality is for
people who have been there I'm in the
second group do you see the white light
or anything did you have any experience
like that did I have one any like white
light experience no no white light
experience I was there and surrounded by
balls there were about as big as
volleyballs moving all around me amber
magenta white gold and I was about a
foot and a half long and a quarter of an
inch wide and that's your soul and your
soul is housed in the column of your
spine hey I knew I could wake you up
yeah he grabbed horses he was a trained
attention when now he wasn't and I heard
column of my spine and I was floating
his spiritual space with these balls all
around me and three of them came up to
me the one on the left was abalone
mother-of-pearl right and that spoke to
me in an androgynous voice telling me
where I was going what I need to do and
I could come with them now
nobody did it sound like that little guy
scape or whatever his name was
now you shall like me get away from here
Mac who's what now who is smack smack oh
not smack smack smack smack oh it's it s
M ake a smack smack not smack smack I
said it right
yeah it's me smack smack smack you like
you like my pants okay chip likes your
box yeah it's a garbage oh man you guys
are so funny with each other is it funny
you're not funny at all but to each
other no it's running cos smack when a
woodchip came chip is an hour Mac left
yeah you strip chip chipper says a
Kalani's he takes our chip chip person
takes over the body of Jin or Jefferson
Zack takes on the body of chip Jefferson
is not a legal name it is what's Lyle
funny oh here's Lyle Lyle chip-chip
person he is a person who sometimes
takes over the body of Jim Norton hey
probably I got I got news for you so
tell me you got to find a different way
to entertain yourself what do you mean
I mean figure out something smarter yeah
please but I was here talking to smack a
minute ago what is pterence well smack
yeah what's the difference with smack
and chip yeah with no no they're two
different identities I see just like you
uh-huh and your buddy is absolutely just
like the camera man over there that's
d-bag yeah this man who d-bag d-bag yeah
what's D stand for douche yeah yeah
vomits a lot
a sick boy man you guys hilarity is very
very moist dan I'm gonna stay here all
day yes yes please do by the way that's
is that your that's your son Jake my
rights Joe you see behind me let me tell
you something you know what is gravy his
first identity I love that movie and
you're very scary in that movie very
intimidating yeah yeah yeah his first
movie was when he was five years old I
was doing a picture with Dustin Hoffman
called straight time and I needed a
sudden it doesn't said what about Jake
and we interviewed different putting it
together and he
he chose his own name one to be Henry
and he came out he did every scene in
one take because he said I'm only going
to do this scene once because I'm
drawing some trucks and we went okay and
so we went through it he did it perfect
on the way home her driving home and I
said Jake you did a great job today you
did everything in one take
you chose her own name what do you think
acting what do you think about acting
now and he said I think it's a dumbest
thing I've ever done
they didn't like that I said well why
did you think he's dumb everything was
perfect on there why do you think it's
dumb because all you do is pretend
except you play like you're not
pretending and I'd rather be drawing a
truck yeah I get that when you're five I
can understand drag cannot be appealing
Fitz sure that I sounded like that yeah
it kind of sounded like smack yeah it's
not a little likes me I don't know
genetic thing or not her or what but no
I I did think acting was kind of a silly
endeavor at the time and um I do like
the fact that he's coined that phrase
and it it actually is one of those
things it makes me think because after
25 years of doing this myself it's like
yeah you know the reality of it is yeah
you do pretend and you play like you're
not pretending and so do a kid it's
really kinda brilliant you know we're
playing cowboys and Indians we're doing
cowboys and Indians of course I guess
that's so politically incorrect I'm
probably gonna get don't tweet me please
well what did you want to do when you
were five what did you want to do he
wanted to dress weird when I was busy
drawing truck yeah yeah
in his fourth I've gotten really into
the whole desert racing thing out in
California and Baja and I'll let that's
been one of my lifelong in endeavors but
you know at the age of five she was
really into playing drums because he had
his drum set in the living room because
he he got his start in in the
entertainment industry by being a
drummer in 1966 in a band that got a
record deal that seems dangerous though
like if you're racing now knowing that
your dad had the accident that he had
yeah well you know I've always worn a
helmet right that's the difference yeah
it's as simple as that isn't it yeah and
I got a cage around me right so you ever
you ever worry about your son doing a
moving quickly in vehicles no no this
kid is great yeah I helped him put an
engine into a pickup truck and he built
saying he saw him build a witnessed in
building a truck when we lived in Malibu
West he did it all from scratch and
there's this kid is doing this and
making a train track out of an N train
which is very small and building a
bridge on a matchsticks
just detailed details they telling just
walk by and go hey that's good I wasn't
with my son as I should have been in my
heart but that I see a no but you're
here now
right I'm here now yeah here now hey how
does the rest of the cast of this play
that is playing at the time squares
theater Center it's called perfect crime
now through December 4th only it's a
very limited run where you can see Gary
Busey but how does the rest of the cast
deal with you because you know I don't
take this the wrong way but you you're a
bit of a handful well that's okay yeah I
that does come with my dinner right the
situation is they're lovely
everyone's lovely in kathryn.russell who
plays the lead she is fantastic she's
got she's got batteries in her that came
from another dimension because she
doesn't quit she cheats just acting she
goes and does this she auditions and
she's back doing the play we made you do
this one like as opposed to I'm sure
you've been offered other plays over the
years how come you haven't done them and
just wanted to do this one I had I was
doing something else oh you always been
Roger X yeah other projects the only
reason I asked you about the rest of the
cast is I remember the only time I've
seen you perform as part of a team is
the two seasons of Celebrity Apprentice
and in those seasons people got
frustrated with you if I remember
correctly that's where you look at what
frustrated with you I saw it on TV I
would they were you know what the you
know what the truth is tell me they were
frustrated with themselves and they were
projecting their frustration with
themselves onto me huh and because that
mr. Trump took a very big shine to you
yeah you liked you yeah Donald would
write my name down the top of the list
women came to this Larry Prentice it's
Larry penance all-stars I was on the
team that won with Trace Adkins right
what do you like so much about you who
Trump what do you like to make you so
much I don't know
I don't know he's right there in the
boardroom he called me a genius or a
brilliant mind don't know where he's
coming from and there there's a common
thing between me and tano and it's just
a frequency you know that we have
together and it works it works great and
very happy to have done this I gotta
tell you one of the most hilarious
things that happen to me that last year
I have a daughter that's four years old
and we took her to a new preschool at
last year's my granddaughter she would
have been three and so you know you mean
the parents the other kids and and I see
I see these other two parents and one of
them is this tall beautiful blonde woman
and then her husband is this guy that's
got a big long gray goatee and tattoos
all over his arms you know and so she
says to me she goes um she goes you Jake
right your dad's your dad's Gary right
and and this is of course when Celebrity
Apprentice is going on and I said yeah
yeah my dad's Gary and and she said you
shake Gary yeah you and that is your
name and and she said she said my dad's
meatloaf I was like that's cool all
right you know and we both had a big
laugh because you know is sort of like
one of those moments of our crazy dads
fighting over a shopping basket with
some painting yeah and there we were
with our kids and they're playing
together so is uh
what is the biggest misinterpretation
people have about your father I think
the biggest misinterpretation and I even
get flack for it like oh my agent will
tell me yeah the casting people don't
want to see you because you're crazy
what do you mean I'm crazy well they've
seen your dad but not me um and I think
the misconception about him is that he's
this crazy sort of volatile wild
unpredictable person I think out of
rhythm I think that one of the things
that they don't understand is is is that
he he's probably one of the the biggest
hearted kind-hearted most generous
people and extremely sensitive and
extremely intuitive and probably one of
the most brilliant people that I've ever
met and it's one thing that that doesn't
really go down do you think the
reputation for being crazy is over
over a unfairly kind of surpass
reputation being a great actor and a
good person well as Hillary Clinton said
there's a there's a personal side and
there's a public and you get true Gary
you that brilliant let him finish
yep and you know my grandfather his dad
was was a Navy Seabee an engineer he was
an extremely bright man he was an
architect and in on the genius level of
IQ and I think that there's a genetic
thing and dad's not far off from that
yeah he had a motorcycle accident and
that does make him a little
short-tempered and it you know he needs
a little more not anymore not anymore
sometimes you get angry though no but I
think it's a frustration it's something
what
what's the neurofeedback neurofeedback
neurofeedback I go see a girl named
Shirley Stephanie 9do and she puts a
four little little round things like
batteries on your skull and then you
watch a video and she has a machine
watching your brainwaves and she is it's
it's like licking her your brain waves
go and how you're thinking I'm I'm great
I'm even what she said it's she said
it's correct now to get up here and it's
correcting your brain waves I don't know
and I think there's a consideration to
that that also is not really publicizing
that is dad was uh I think he really
would have benefited what really would
have served him well is if he had
started doing Broadway plays thirty
years ago because one thing that he
thrives on is the interaction with other
people right lovely audio and he loves
the audience and yet in the film
industry when you're working on a film
you've got like four people around the
camera you know couple actors camera guy
director and that's about it it is shame
they go cut it's in the can okay let's
go on the other one and then it's quiet
there's none of this and so right you
like that right he loves edits right I
love it he spent I've never heard it the
best for ladies conceptually I love it
right okay so he's the better part of
the 80s in the 90's running around a
local rock clubs playing music music and
and and really thriving on the crowd and
the people and and the interaction and
had he just done Broadway 20 years ago
I think it really would have served him
well so this
is going to be a fantastic endeavor and
that's why I came to see opening what
Broadway had been harder back then
though if the light you know lifestyle
wasn't as healthy as it is now would
Broadway have been harder to do with the
drinking and the drugs that might have
been a harder thing to know why it
wasn't drinking my drug of choice was a
c-note okay and I mean the hundred
dollar bill and what starts with C sure
and deed on that made the third nineteen
ninety five and couldn't figure out why
I was doing that I was dancing with the
devil and the situation is when you
dance with the devil
don't let him lead you do the leading of
the dancing in the minute the songs over
maybe two beats before the songs over
remove yourself from the dancing ring
with the devil right make sense
anything and you said you're doing the
the thing with getting angry is it hard
not to get angry with the brain injury
does that cause you to fire off quickly
and what what why you're just angry well
you was impulsive okay so so how do you
like control the impulsiveness look easy
it's easy where I am down 72 years old
going through what I've gone through
having this beautiful firstborn son Jake
and having the new son Luke who's six
years old and having my daughter Electra
have a strong family around me with
nothing but love it's like living with
angels and the situation with losing my
temper comes from anger I'm going to
take the letters of spell anger and give
you abuse ISM ang ER stands for right
another negative grievance explaining
rage that works because that works
entirely the word hate the word hate
hade yes yes has please that stands for
holding a treacherous energy right now I
want to do that no nobody wants to do
that it's no good do you think a lot of
people around here they were talking
about they think that you're going to
end up in the White House now because
you and Trump have this relationship
that you're going to end up somewhere in
the cabinet or doing something I won't
end up there but I wash I'll be going
there I'll be going there I'm going to
I'm going to work on a dance contest
between Pence and Trump analiza rice and
yeah and maybe who's
another girl no no she's not there
anymore so we won't mention that I'm not
going to do a dance contest I'm just
going to say hello to a good friend of
mine I'm so proud of him for doing what
he did yeah
yeah we surprised he won an hour wait a
minute I'm so proud of him for doing
what he is we surprised do you honor
because you know him you aren't
surprised I knew he's going to win to
the beginning you did and we're watching
the Steffi now are watching the
elections that not on TV yeah but who
was asleep turned it off and I got up
morning about 5:00 a.m. and she said
hello mm-hmm you're not gonna say what
she's like when people quote me okay I
can't say any more are you here for
everything you can't paraphrase you
every can of what a paraphrase she did
want to be quoted so maybe you could
paragraph right right so another great
thing that people don't know about is
the Busey isms actually came out of the
brain injury uh part of the part of his
healing was putting words together and
and and learning how to speak my mother
and I had to teach him how to speak and
how to eat and how to walk and he was
you know pretty much you know comatose
in a wheelchair so when he was learning
how to talk he was like he said he was
due to be released out of the hospital
because he said my shoes or to the bed
and something I can special so that type
of thing was sort of spurned the whole
Busey ISM thing which was him trying to
put meaning on things and understand the
language my first vision was I was
writing in a book it was all about the
past it was about being betrayed just
like her what have I did why why this
and white has had that wagon and I
realized man you're talking about the
past where are you I mean I'm in the now
now okay and now I came to me now stands
for no other way
boom because you got a now join her in
the now and see the past is his history
the factors of mystery and being in the
now is a present because they call it
the presence we have to wrap you up and
let you go you don't know I'm not done
yeah we're not trying through that
telling us and by the way I say as long
as you I did like witnessing what we saw
a moment ago which was what he said at
the beginning of the interview agreeing
with
the wife yes I noticed quite shocking
wasn't it
yeah it was amazing she stopped Gary in
his tracks it was possible nope but Gary
was like alright then it's an Ellen is
if it sign and Gary zipped it oh yeah
head smart man yeah you know when she
starts talking my brain freezes okay
baby yeah we've been good being here
Gary
everybody can see a perfect crime now
through December 4th at Times Square's
theater center you can go - perfect -
crime calm get tickets it's right in the
middle of Times Square across the street
from Mike it's right by Caroline's I
would like to go see this yeah you know
unique ah you know you need to because
that was y'all that respect running out
the door but how you need to go see it
because I'm here for two weeks right see
it immediately don't hesitate it's going
to sell out he's only gonna be here for
two weeks and who knows maybe smack will
show up in the middle of the place yeah
I'll be there thank you Gary Busey